what's going on everyone i want to tell
you a story that was really impactful
for me earlier on in my life
uh in my business career and it was when
laila and i
went to the pirates who have mastermind
now if you've ever you know listened to
my podcast or you've been on this
channel um
i've talked about this before but it was
one of the most impactful experiences of
my life and it was because i had
multiple mentors who made more than me
um speak belief into me and
also made sure that i capitalized on the
fat pitch all right and so i'll tell you
how this went so i was
laylee and i just got married this was
2017 may
we had just gone from you know me almost
losing everything
to this business that we just shifted
from a done for you flying out
doing gym turnarounds to a consulting
service um teaching other people how to
do our model
and we were doing we were like in our
second month and doing 350 000 a month
it was
insane um and it was just layla me and
an assistant over selling over the
kitchen table it was absolutely bananas
um i didn't even know we made more money
than i knew what to even do with it was
it was crazy you know
we're living on 1200 a month and taking
home 340 of 350 000 a month it was crazy
and so anyways i got invited to an
eight-figure mastermind and clearly if
you're doing the math there i'm not
making any figures
and i felt like really out of place i
was like are you sure you want me to
come and he was like yeah dude you're
gonna like he's like you're gonna blow
past eight figures
like really and so first person that
spoken to me was russell
which is why i'm always grateful for
that and so he saw something in me that
i couldn't see for myself which is why
i think it's so valuable to to pay for
mentorships and pay for
um you know people who are ahead of you
to
to to give you perspective that you lack
because a lot of times it's beliefs it's
the things that you don't see that kill
you
right and that and that prevent you from
succeeding
and so anyways we get to this event i'm
super nervous this because all these
guys are like titan they're all doing
you know 10 million 20 million 30
million
and uh i think russell at the time i
think they were doing 35
um to show you how long ago it was cause
now i think they're doing 150.
and uh i got up there it was finally my
turn
and i you know i wrote on the board and
i told how our whole process worked and
how much money our gyms are making on
average
and um jason fladland
uh actually i'll start with what alex
started says alex sharpen was in the
room and he's like you have 100 million
business right now and you don't even
know it
and i remember feeling like the air was
sucked out of the room
because i felt all of a sudden i was
like really proud of what i had
accomplished but
all these guys made so much more money
than me that they were they were like
dude you need to
like you need to step on the gas and i
was like what they're like you've got a
huge thing in front of you if you if you
like like you need to take advantage of
this and at the time i was saying how i
was like okay we're making 350 a month
and i want to start a supplement company
and they were like why would you want to
start a supplement company just double
your ad spend because you're not
spending anything on ads right now and i
was like okay i guess i'll do that
because i listen to these guys because i
made more money than me i was like all
right
and so that was end of my end all so
rather than starting another business i
just kept doing the thing that i was
doing which ended up being an amazing
piece of advice for them to give me and
i probably would have sabotaged myself i
had not paid for that so it's like if
you ever have the opportunity to spend
more than you're probably comfortable
with to be surrounded by people who make
a lot more money than you you will
almost always disproportionately
and every time in my life i've always
disproportionately moved up faster
when i can surround myself and figure
out i want them to speak into me and
tell me what i cannot see
right i'm like tell me what i'm missing
what am i not seeing that you can see
right because
for whatever your business is right or
whatever your skill set is i'm sure that
there's if someone who's
who's doing something that you are very
good at you can immediately see what's
going on it doesn't take it takes you
two seconds right you're like oh this is
what's wrong this is wrong this is wrong
when i look at a business now i can be
like oh this is the issue right
it's immediate but when you don't have
the context you just run your head in
the wall wondering what's going on
right so anyways after the um my little
presentation was over jason flatland
came up to me and he had done a hundred
million dollars on webinars and i was
like man this guy's
super smart he was you know he was
really aggressive and bright and i was
like man we gotta figure something out
um or i don't want to say anything
stupid and so anyways he comes up to me
and he said
you need to 10x overnight and i was like
what he said
if you what you're saying is true and
you're making jim's this much money
he's like someone bigger than you who
already has all your customer base is
going to take
everything you have and distribute it i
was like what he's like they're going to
take
everything you have and just destroy you
before you even have a chance
and i just felt even worse after this
right i feel this pit in my stomach and
then he leaned into me
and he said when it when it gets easy is
when you go hard
and i remember how much i was shaken by
that and layla was right next to me and
i was like when it gets easy is when i
go hard
when it gets easy is when you go hard i
was like huh
and the biggest gift i got from those
guys there was that this was my
fat pitch right there are only a handful
of opportunities that present themselves
in the course of
you know entrepreneurs career where you
have the opportunity you have the skill
um
and like basically the stars align right
now that being said you have to
develop the skills so that when the
opportunity presents itself you can
knock it out of the park and step up to
the plate
but when i listen to you know warren
buffett and he talks about the
investments right
they they choose very sparingly what
things they're going to invest in but
when they do they back they load the
truck up they go all
in you know you find your sphere of
confidence in and you just get pitches
all day long
right just like a baseball analogy you
get pitched over and over but you have
no strikeouts right there's no way to
strike out
you just have to wait and wait and wait
until you get the perfect pitch that fat
pitch that's in your sweet spot
and then you step up and you knock it
out of the park and if you look at the
people who are the wealthiest in the
world
invariably the vast majority
made their money with one vehicle they
made all of their wealth or the vast
majority of their wealth with one
vehicle and then
after they made their wealth then they
diversified right
and so this is one of the big issues
that i feel like i see in the internet
culture and the instagram culture
is they're like you gotta have like they
you know billionaires have seven
you know revenue streams yes but they
didn't have that to get there
right now i have lots of revenue streams
but i didn't
have that building this right and so the
idea is it looks much more like an
umbrella you've got
one straight path all the way up on one
vehicle where you're all in invested
which is your business
most of the time or your career and then
it balloons out then it umbrellas out
and then you sprinkle those investments
and other things because you're overly
leveraged in one business but every
single one of them most of the guys that
you see all of them came from
one one thing that made their money and
then they sprinkled it out
on top of the other vehicles and so um
if you listen to garyvee even he talked
about one of his biggest regrets was how
when
google ads were really cheap that he
should have spent more for wine library
and all of these things kind of collided
at the same time in my life where i had
you know
i'm listening to gary he was saying you
know i i wish i had spent more
right and i had jason saying hey when it
gets easy is when you need to go hard
all these guys are going to take all
your stuff
and then you know scharfen's saying hey
you've got 100 million dollar company
and you don't even know it
and then you know russell's like you're
gonna blow past eight figures and all of
this stuff was spoken into me when i was
just a kid like you gotta understand
like
i didn't know anything like i knew
nothing we're doing 300 a month and i
was like holy crap like what
is going on is this legal i don't want
to mess it up like it's just like holy
you know
and um and so but because of their
encouragement
rather than a distract myself and start
another business right
all we did is we i followed what they
said
i i 5x my ads been and
and then it just took off like a
freaking rocket you know i mean we went
from you know 350 to 1.5 million in the
next like five months
as in per month and so it was just
blockers
and i just listened to what they had
said and so
my my my take away from this and me
sharing the story is that i don't know
what pitches you have in front of you
there are only a certain amount of times
where we're going to get that fat
pitch and i think we might the point of
this video is that
if it is easy for you right now
this is the time to step up i was
talking to some entrepreneurs that were
younger not that long ago
and they went from you know next to
nothing
i think not next to nothing i think they
were doing that that sounds horrible
what about to say so they were doing
like one or two million dollars a year
um
i didn't mean it like that but their
last month they they made like 20 or 30
thousand dollars
in their last month of the year and then
the next month they they hit this offer
out of the freaking park
and they uh they did three million and
they did five million the next month in
revenue i mean that's insanity
i mean i've i've never heard of anything
growing that fast
without like a jv you know like some
sort of joint venture thing like never
in my life i've heard someone grow that
fast
and they were like yeah you know we're
trying to like
enjoy the fruits of our labor and you
know kind of like not spend a ton of
time on the business you know
on the business and i wanted and i got
to have the opportunity to be the
the older person in the situation
because i could see in them what i
imagine people saw in me which was like
you've got a hot one right now
like you need to ride it hard like when
like
strike when the iron is hot right when
the fat pitch comes you step up and you
put everything you've got into it
and so like this is not the time to try
and figure out work life balance because
you're going to have this finite window
where you're going to make
disproportionate amounts of money where
you're going to make your generational
wealth in this short gap
and we just have to hope that when that
opportunity presents itself
we take full advantage right if you're
going to california
and during the gold rush in 1849 and you
start panning for gold and you start
getting gold
that's not the time to say you know what
i've made it i'm going to stay at home
i'm only going to pan you know for gold
an hour to a day
um of course not right because you'd be
like i got a pen i got to trade because
it takes much gold out of this river is
humanly possible it seems obvious to us
from the outside but when you're in it
you have all these other things that are
going on in your mind right and the
thing is is that opportunity like many
are finite right there's a defined
period of time where you're going to be
able to ride that wave and be early on
it and crush it
and so most people who are very wealthy
had one big pitch that they swung hard
on
and and then after they've made it then
they sprinkle their other investments
just don't
try and reverse engineer the wrong
sequence
and so anyways hope this is valuable for
you it was a huge moment in my life
i don't know where you're at i don't
know if your fat pitch is coming i don't
know if it already came and you wish
you'd swung harder or you're
on the plate right now and the ball is
right in front of you i don't know where
you're at
but hopefully this uh this story that
changed my life
um can help someone else so anyways lots
of love keeping awesome i'll catch you
guys on the flip side
bye